can we start off talking about who I
think the real stars of this film are is
there any fear that they're gonna really
steal the spotlight from you guys you
guys showed me totally stole the show
the first time to the extent the nifflas
like negotiating hard for the second
there was a script I read where it
wasn't in it because they were really
worried yeah I'm gonna get it even
offered his own show I think Ella and
it'll be fantastic yeah do you guys
still get a kick out of jumping no sorry
being on a plane and then she has no
dick doing the magic like using a wands
doing the magic saying the spells it's
like a dream come true for anything is
Jude does the magic I did pearl 11 and
that was reminded that of course CGI is
now available right no making put my
card trick away and sort of sat on my
hands I also put a lot of effort into
trying to do all these one work and then
read the scripts and I've got like I
think I use it once yeah I think I just
did one little bit it's really
nerve-wracking on set where they added
something on the day and they say you
know just do a little thing with your
wand it's like whoa
get it you know because it is so much
fun to sort of work out the distinctive
movements for various actions and we get
exactly what I put so much into our one
little sink one moment I think Newt
would do it like new ones no yeah the
level of fandom for the Wizarding World
is out of well as well it's crazy yeah
and were you surprised at all stepping
into it I mean you had to know I was
sure yeah I've never experienced
anything like it right and I think what
it what struck me was the real personal
impression it makes and then when you
step back and you realise the magic that
the impact is because JK Rowling has
written these books and created this
world that somehow the characters still
have such a familiar they go through
such familiar crises they go they are
they are still anti-heroes they aren't
you know obvious heroes they they carry
problems they have self-doubt and then
that is inside this wonderful world of
magic which gives it this incredible
excuse of escape you know so it's it's
it really impacts people and people care
about it or even just the opportunity to
choose what house you might be in in
Hogwarts so rather than make good or bad
you look at the kind of different
personality drags and characteristics
that you might share